an election that left many Brazilians in
tears some from happiness
others from the heartbreaking defeat of
their candidate
Victorious left-wing candidate luisi
nacion Lula da Silva arrived to address
Brazilians at his headquarters when it
was confirmed that he'd narrowly beaten
incumbent president Jade
bolsonaroided
[Music]
this is the victory of an immense
Democratic movement that was formed
Beyond political parties or ideologies
or personal interests so that democracy
could Triumph
it's been an astonishing comeback for
Brazil's first working-class president
who served two successful terms from
2003 to the end of 2010 but who was
later imprisoned for corruption the
conviction was later overturned allowing
him to run for a third term today's
election is a little bit different
because what we see is an election to
defeat bolsonaro to to get over these
four very difficult time for very
difficult years for Brazilians in
general especially for minorities
that's why Diana was crying
we are women we are artists we are part
of the LGBT community it's been very
difficult to live in a country that
doesn't tolerate people as they are
starting today that will start a change
but it won't be so simple after a bitter
election that split Brazil in half
the victory celebrations and speeches
are understandable but they do not hide
the fact that President Jade bolsonaro
has yet to come save defeat and neither
have many of his staunchest supporters
and that doesn't vote well for what will
clearly be the next government's
greatest Challenge and that is to make
Brazil whole again
you while leaders of both houses of
Congress congratulated Lula for his win
some bolsonaro supporters called for
military intervention
this is a fraud and if people have to
call on the Army the Army must intervene
bolsonaro himself hasn't said a word in
public since casting his vote the
question is whether he plans to make
good on earlier threats not to accept
the election outcome Lucia Newman Al
Jazeera Sao Paulo